with over four decades of Star Wars
movies books and TV shows to pour over
fans have uncovered a myriad of mistakes
and inconsistencies in the universe over
the years
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and in this video I'll be explaining how
the new solo film addresses or fixes
five intriguing Star Wars movie mistakes
contradictions and unanswered questions
if you're new here I do regular movie
breakdown so subscribe to get all my new
Star Wars videos and leave a comment as
well for a chance to win a Star Wars
Funko pop spoilers ahead for the solo
movie so take care if you've not seen it
yet something that's puzzled die hard
Star Wars fans for a while is how the
Millennium Falcon can have a
conversation with droids like c-3po and
r2d2 sir
I don't know where your ship don't
communicate but it has a most peculiar
done in it
I believe sir it says that the power
coupling on the negative axis has been
polarized and the solo movie finally
reveals that it's Lando's cranky droid
l-3 who's behind the Millennium Falcon's
rather quirky personality after l3 kicks
off a droid rebellion on Castle she gets
blasted and her system starts failing
Lando manages to save part of her and
takes her onto the Millennium Falcon
during their escape the crew have to
take a shortcut through the Maelstrom
which is extremely dangerous but Han
points out the l3 has the best
navigational database in the galaxy and
suggest downloading her brain into the
Falcons computer l3 then maps the area
and finds the best way out so in the
words of Lando she's a part of the ship
now this also fits something revealed in
the last Jedi novelization where it said
that the Falcon has always been
cantankerous and that one of its brains
had a fondness for both romantic gossip
and dirty jokes which fits in well with
lt''s personality as we saw it in the
solo movie it might also explain why
Lando is still protective of the ship
when we meet him in the Empire Strikes
Back as it still houses a consciousness
so to speak of his old friend by the way
el threes brain module originated as an
r3 astromech brain which also ties in
neatly with the specs for the Millennium
Falcon which state the ship's computer
is made up of three droid brains one of
which is an r3 astromech when we first
meet han Solo in a new hope he boasts
about how the Millennium Falcon made the
Kessel run in
under 12 parsecs since then though
canons stories have thrown doubt on
whether hands achievement is actually
true in the Canon novel a new hope the
princess the scoundrel and the farm boy
is revealed that when hand makes his
boast in the Mos Eisley cantina it's
actually a lie and the obi-wan probably
knew better and amusingly by the time of
the force awakens it seems that Rey's
heard stories that it actually took
around 14 parsecs this is a ship that
made the Kessel run in 14 parsecs 1214
the solo movie weighs in on the
confusion when after completing the run
hand bows to the guy handling the fuel
cells that he just did the Kessel run in
12 parsecs then Chewie seems to object
to this claim and Han replies not if you
round down buddy now exactly how much
rounding down is going on here isn't
revealed but it sounds like those 14
parsecs mentioned in the force awakens
might be closer to the truth and fans
thought when we first saw that scene if
you watch or more accurately listened to
a Star Wars movie you'll start to notice
that names are often pronounced
inconsistently something to impart to
the mix of American and British actors
and their differing accents and there's
one major character in particular who's
names been setting consistently
throughout the movies unsolo will take
care of yourself you think that after
what you did to Han Han we need you
always giving Han to this bounty what
about Han
princess you'll find that we're short
one Han Solo
your Han Solo goodness Han Solo you are
the Han Solo they fought with the
rebellion I'm so long in the original
trilogy many American actors say Han
while British actors pronounce it's han
carrie fisher's leia switches between
Han and Han and George Lucas himself
says hand while Lando repeatedly
pronounces it hand despite Billy Dee
Williams being American the solo movie
decides to acknowledge this
inconsistency explaining it in the scene
were hand meets Lando for the first time
on saw ask you a question captain
Calrissian anything him that's hard but
that's okay perhaps Lando was just
trying to put Han off his game but it
seems like the pronunciation stuck and
we now have an explanation for the way
Lando says it broke one already gave us
a little theory about why stormtroopers
so often missed their targets when it
comes to force users but the solo movie
takes the explanation of stage further
and answers a perennial question of how
imperial troops can be so generally
incompetent when shooting even people
who aren't force sensitive in a bit of
meta-commentary
after removing a mud trooper uniform Jon
Favreau's alien character Rio says how
do they breathe in these suits it's so
stuffy no wonder they're such lousy
pilots you can't turn your head you
can't breathe you can't hear each other
obviously he's not directly addressing
stormtrooper incompetence rather mud
troopers but it seems reasonable to
assume that stormtroopers also suffer
from having to work clunky stuffy suits
as well hence the reason for their
infamous inability to shoot accurately
at the end of solo the movie tackles the
controversial change that George Lucas
made when he reacted the original Star
Wars for the 1997 special edition
re-release Lucas altered the scene in
the cantina were bounty hunter Greedo
corners han about the money he owes
Jabbar originally after Han says over my
dead body
Guido brags that he's looking forward to
this prompting hand to shoot him dead
George Lucas was unhappy with this
portrayal of Han saying it showed him to
be a cold-blooded killer so for the 1997
release he added frame showing green
shooting hand first but missing
curiously the 2004 DVD release edited
the scene again having Greedo and hand
shoot each other around the same time
the solo movie heavily implies at hand
most probably did shoot first in the
cantina because he does the same to
Beckett shooting him dead as he's
talking and readying his own gun Solo
sets hands character up as someone
operating in a morally gray area both
willing to help out the good guys IM f--
is nest and also ending up working for
people like Jabba the Hutt and its hands
transition from rogue to hero in a new
hope that many fans love about the
character which is why it feels
important that solo finally establishes
that yes hand did shoot first solo was
absolutely packed with Star Wars Easter
eggs and connections so were there any
other issues you spotted that the movie
fixed or answered and did you notice any
new plot holes in the movie let me know
in the comments and make sure you're
subscribed to enter my Star Wars Funko
pop giveaway if you enjoyed this I
really appreciate a thumbs up and you're
sharing the video plus you can tap left
for my breakdown of what Darth Maul's
reveal means for an obi-wan movie or tap
right for my full Star Wars playlist
thanks for watching and see you next
time you PK movie lovers